hi I'm Ryan right and i'm gerry welcome
to real reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to see zero dark
thirty so let's hang out and talk about
this really fun movie so much fun bro
Ryan's consensus there are very strong
reasons to watch zero dark thirty there
are very strong reasons to watch zero
dark thirty um Jerry's consensus there
there are reasons someone would want to
see this movie there are reasons why
someone will want to watch this movie
reason to see number one Jessica
Chastain she's perfect in this role I
believe she deserves the oscar for her
performance she's subtle but amid so
much believable emotion plus she's
beautiful it's interesting to see how
she goes from being sort of disturbed at
the beginning than to watch you know the
process of her detaching from humanity
and then you know sort of doing things
that she wouldn't have originally done
all in service of the greater good
reason to see number two Jason Clark
this dude is an authentic actor he's
very much a layered supporting character
and each layer he brings to the
performance is just as authentic as the
next yeah I mean he certainly brings a
lot of dimension to the roll out of this
super serious movie he's probably the
most fun guy to watch yeah you do sort
of learn to like him even though you
meet him doing these awful things reason
to see number three the supporting cast
do this Cass is perfect none of the
characters ever seem to be tilted in any
direction it would have been easy to
make a lot of these characters
stereotypes and they really avoid that
it really feels like you're watching
people and not actors just this whole
cast was extremely authentic reason to
see number for directing and writing
this movie is not for everybody yeah
this Phyllis is it's sort of deeply
unsettling to me deeply distressing
really overwhelming you know it feels
very unbiased in its execution
everything feels real it doesn't feel
like a movie or a documentary it just
sort of feels like you're
you're peering over someone's shoulder
the whole time just sort of fly on the
wall it's like being shoved down a
rabbit hole yeah it really feels like
you're there yeah I was never combed
kathryn bigelow knows how to create
events that we as American citizens
already know about yet many events
twists and turns still feel very
unexpected so I can only imagine how if
you don't know about this event prior to
the movie how we as an audience member
you're going to react it's weird cuz
it's a thriller but I wouldn't call it
an exciting thriller just because of how
raw it is yeah it's not exciting can't
call it exciting cuz it's didn't feel
like you enjoyed the xperia it's not an
experience I don't I don't think you can
really enjoy yeah yeah you can still
admire you can appreciate it can impact
you but it's not I wouldn't say it's
like thrilling in that way or exciting
or like oh I can't wait to see what
happens next you just the whole time
just like I really hope something else
doesn't blow up what yeah you're just
waiting for relief to settle in before
we started filming you used the example
of the devil's rejects which is a movie
that I love and yes you know that movie
is very intense you know it's extreme
and there's a lot of stuff that's hard
to swallow and while I wouldn't force
anyone to watch it there are some people
where I would say you know I think you
might dig this you know be forewarned
its extreme but you might like it and
that's an experience I would want to
kind of share with somebody for
zero-dark thirty i I really don't know
who would like this movie or not I feel
like if you're already in the position
to go see it you're probably gonna see
it anyway so I wouldn't deter anyone
from seeing it if you want to go but
it's not I don't want to go out and be
like hey you gotta watch this you know
put yourself through this experience I
guess if I had a gun in my head I would
i would say that yes I recommend it I
mean there's no denying the quality of
the experience and there is no denying
the intent of the filmmakers are
strongly you know realized and met you
know regardless of whether or not you
like this movie there's absolutely no
denying that Kathryn Bigelow's
intentions were clearly met plus I saw
the trailer for
after earth you know the pursuit of
happiness part 2 yeah reasons not to see
I wouldn't say there are reasons not to
see this movie but on the same token
that from the very second it started it
sort of hit me like a ton of bricks and
it was a it was it's a master class in
hard to get through just be prepared for
that you might leave and and find
yourself you know very affected by it
you know because I've been kind of in a
funk since I saw it in the in this day
it's easy to lose sight of the things
that happen in the world cuz they're all
so far away this movie sort of brings
them right into your face and like look
at them and that's a hard thing to go
through
you